[Music]
in back from the dead news
submitted by Joe's biggest fan Oh the
big fan
Oh what does no name if you're his
biggest fan hmm huh he doesn't have one
mouthing [ __ ] I don't know him I do I
know you do
that's r2d2 but like Halloween oh you're
jealous a yell experiment to reanimate
dead brains is receiving backlash from
an ethics professor how do you reanimate
dead brain mm-hmm electro wave sure that
they resuscitated it a [ __ ] pig brain
yeah is that what it is yeah okay I'm in
the [ __ ] it was it was dead and they
were able yeah make it do stuff again
[ __ ] zombie but reanimated that's so
dampens like the brains dead and then
now it's back alive and it's working
this is like really crappy awesome I'm
going to Mars that's like a PC now let's
like you just reboot so last month Yale
University announced they had
successfully resurrected the brains of
more than 100 slaughtered Pig what the
mob what I have to do so many yeah I do
all the testing yeah and so they're
saying that the cells were still healthy
well so they did not regain
consciousness they couldn't think of
anything but it the cells were there
like they they came back to life to turn
them back at the vegetables yeah you
know Sambi apocalypse like that's
exactly what they're trying to start I
do that brain wiped out huh everything
wiped out so they were dated they
weren't like it it was just like
everything was working there's activity
yeah and open up their eyes like how
well some [ __ ] slaps I think
they only had the brains themself but
they were from slaughtered pigs so it's
like Futurama I imagine them hitting a
switch and then you just hear like oh
wait that was like oh [ __ ] words
well you know what they should do but
you weren't able to keep these brains
live for up to 36 hours and then it dies
and then well I don't know what happens
after but the science is the whole point
of this is the fact that the scientists
are saying that this whole process can
also work in primates aka human yeah and
that it is possible to restore
consciousness and awareness later on
with their studies okay so before I was
like zombie apocalypse weird but now I
feel like it's gonna happen like chills
I love this idea what's really cool
about this though so these are
slaughtered pigs right so people that
haven't reached the end of their lives
that can benefit from this so people
that got killed or people are gonna car
accident weight then the end of their
lives but now when you're like 12 like
if you're like 90 years old this isn't
gonna work on you but if you're like
like let's say I've heard 15 get hit by
a car yeah
natural selections are highly over
popular over populated oh my god Panther
yes I did what kind of a Condor Wakanda
we have a baby dude you guys are bad as
minorities you're obligated you would
have cried in the hey we were in a
theatre you're sitting next to us you
don't know is this [ __ ] child
starts crying you're gonna be like oh
who the [ __ ] would bring a baby to you
can't find a babysitter for a second
everyone's used to Mexican mom's doing
that so just go ahead it's coming out on
blu-ray soon yeah what kind of [ __ ] is
that huh what kind eyes
yeah here is the baby home Oh your
stupid eyes cuz the camera box is busy
yeah well I sees your stupid bud fun
[ __ ] I would like to be brought back
from the death if I could do this [ __ ]
oh yeah hurry back [ __ ]
oh like John oh it never more than that
I got more life to [ __ ] give
[ __ ]
I think begin give and live death when
death happens it happens for a reason to
time I'ma be immortal I'm gonna be a guy
you don't even know I'm not gonna die
either oh no no no but my soul is gonna
forget all the no one ever really died I
got a reset this [ __ ] I got a
do-it-all it's a band any arty you know
why this freaks me out is because they
probably they reanimated it with like
like electricity and [ __ ] right yeah
they used the system of pumps
Frankenstein bro and bags of artificial
blood warm to bottom so no and no
electricity all kind of heaters and bags
of artificial blood yeah Wow like it
said when people have to lose their
lives really really but at the same time
like that's been happening for since the
beginning of life in general well yeah
and now we can change that let's think
we need let's progress we've kind of
been obsessed with this though since
forever because Frankenstein we're not
even that just the elixir of life right
the Fountain of Youth
yeah like the Emperor who drink mercury
in the China oh whoops
you know what this freaks me out is
because with um AI getting so much more
realistic and like robots getting so
much more really Tommy's ready Tom B's I
feel like let's say they find a way to
do this [ __ ] put a [ __ ] brain in a
robot body you feel me and then and then
it's like they're gonna take over and
kill everybody exactly that's what I
want okay my boy you give me the leader
oh okay the night is cool okay yeah all
right do it there's just not enough time
there's just our organic body cannot
[ __ ] handle it like there's not
enough time for anything or you wasted
like
ten years doing [ __ ] drugs they ask
you how you are you just going to say
that you're fine you're not really fine
you just can't get it dan put you on
blast [ __ ] I didn't waste it that's a
life experience okay learn if this can
happen
maybe people and you can be a robot to
do real dude I don't see where the joke
is there I just see a put-down I'm sorry
you waste your leg wasted ten years of
your life being a [ __ ] drug addict
it's like I did I just went past that
part of my life face with your back yeah
this is a affect sad fact damn that down
that's you know you lived a motherless
life for the last 20 years
you've been [ __ ] molested by your dad
for the last seven years Wow burn burn
do real good birth that's not a bird you
scorched the earth that won't allow now
I was just trying to talk about
immortality it's goddamn I'm just
regretting life right now but see that's
the reason why any immortality so much
is cuz I did [ __ ] up all that all that
all those years you see now I need a
hundred more years to kind of make up
for that right hey get away from me you
weirdo
but if everybody lives forever we're
gonna run it like our resources are
gonna run out you know I'm saying yes
that we're prepping Mars oh yeah I
forgot to mention
not everyone me the people that are
worthy worthy the person the person oh
yeah yeah it's not special anymore if
everyone can do it your honor because
we're too overpopulated we already are
that Mars I know that's why when I heard
this thing I'm like stop why no why
we don't need to but what if this is
what the answer is to fight the robots
zombies vs. robots you mean zombie where
do we fit into that but we have our army
right in the [ __ ] robots kill us and
[ __ ] so then we have to like use this to
get us back to life so we have like the
zombie brethren but here's what's [ __ ]
up though right so during the
experiments you they don't tell you how
many other Pig brains they went through
that that maybe turn off like five
minutes and then [ __ ] up so then what
happens to the all the reanimated human
brains when they start doing this that
are kind of conscious right or that are
kind of almost bad but not like do you
know that person is gonna have those
person or are they gonna be the
second-class citizens
Oh God look at my flips everything to be
positive for him that's even more [ __ ]
up for them cuz then you have like these
these second-class citizens where it's
like okay now what is this person
technically a person do they have the
rights that we all have is it well
that's true because then if everyone
mixes there's no normal racism now it's
like hey you're a [ __ ] reboot right
I'm a G so like I never died yet but you
did you're a reboot you're a half-human
yeah like you have these like mutants
running around night when I read this
cuz you know how we don't know
everything that's happening like they
just tell you everything yeah right so
if they're telling us this much mm-hmm
maybe they've already done [ __ ] on
humans ha ha ha and like there's already
human zombies out there we don't know
what people pig pig zombie man mm-hmm
you know maybe they're like little I'm
so glad that I live right now I think
like we have like good enough technology
where I'm pretty happy so my kids are
just gonna be [ __ ] so whatever they'll
deal with it yeah cuz I don't think
we're gonna experience like whatever you
thought up or whatever we're not gonna
be
what experience it cuz we're gonna be
grandparents gonna be our grandkids I'm
gonna be so sour I'll be like 80 years
old so jealous like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
cyborg [ __ ] mother cyborg [ __ ] you
watch altered carbon oh is that that
Netflix puzzle yeah that everyone
thought was like real that they were
like the clips were going viral with a
little zip blocks people yeah yeah
you gotta watch that [ __ ] future I
like I like sci-fi me too I love that
job every two is just that they did it
so which Syfy stranger things that's not
really sci-fi is it what you know
changing things were so successful
Netflix is is bringing on like six more
sci-fi shows because of the success of
strange thank goodness because that's
one of the genres that I look at on
Netflix yeah
[Music]